e
correspondante à Moscou,
Tamara Alteresco.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Ce n'est pas la menace
d'une guerre avec l'Ukraine
qui ouvre les bulletins
de nouvelles de la chaîne
principale en Russie
aujourd'hui, mais plutôt
le 78e anniversaire de
la levée du blocus de Leningrad.
- Vladimir Poutine.
- rérérésident Vladimir Poutine
s'est recueilli seul et
en silence au pied du monument
des victimes. On ne peut que
deviner ce qu'il pense.
Il n'a pas dit un seul mot
en public depuis le 23 décembre
sur cette crise diplomatique
et militaire que l'OTAN l'accuse
d'avoir provoquée en déployant
ses milliers de troupes
à la frontière de l'Ukraine.
Les Russes n'en savent pas plus
et suivent la balle au bond.
"Il y a une sacrée tension
dans l'espace médiatique,
d'un côté comme de l'autre",
dit Pavel Petrov,
qui rentre à la maison.
"Si la télévision d'État
reproche aux Américains
et l l l l'OTAN de démoniser
la Russie, d'attiser
les tensions en brandissant
le risque d'une invasion
de l'Ukraine, nous, les gens,sa,
dit Yuri Sidorenko.
"Chacun a sa propre vérité,
ses propres intérêts à défendre.
Nous avons les nôtres,
dit-il, mais rien
ne justifirrrrrrrrrre."
"Un accord n'est possible que
si les dirigeants agissent
au nom de leurs citoyens."
Et c'est ce que le Kremlin
affirme vouloir faire
en rananananant, sans aucun
compromis possible, l'arrêt
de l'expansion de l'OTAN,
tout comme le retrait
des troupes de l'alliance
l l l l les pays voisins.
"Et à ce chapitre,
nous n'avons pas reçu
de réponse positive des
États-Unis", dit le ministre
Sergueï Lavrov, même si
la lettre reçue de Washington
permet, selon lui, d'espérer
une discussion sérieuse sur
des questions secondaires.
Sur le plat
cette émission d'affaires
publiques, le débat est tendu :
appliquer la force ou
poursuivre le dialogue?
"On cherche le dialogue!",
crie l'animateur, enterré
par ses invités, alors que
sisisisisisie publie à nouveau
des vidéos comme celle-ci,
où l'on voit des centaines
de soldats arriver près
de la frontière de l'Ukraine.
"J'ai peur et c'est pourquoi
je pars rejoindre mes parents
en Italie", a,a,a,a,a,a,
qui étudie à Moscou.
Mais c'est le président
Vladimir Poutine qui décidera
du prochain pas à franchir
et il en profi
faire monter les enchères.
L'OTAN a décidé d'en faire
autant en préparant la riposte.
Tout mouvement diplomatique
est umumumumumumumis
à une manifestation de force,
comme à l'époque de la guerre
froide et avec tous les risques
que ça comprend.
Ici Tamara Alteresco,
Radio-Canada, Mosco